[Music]
range lands make up a large part of the
western United States 85% of Wyoming is
considered rangeland one use we
frequently see on Range land is grazing
by both domestic livestock and Wildlife
this grazing provided by rangelands is
critical for healthy animals but the
health of the rangelands must also be
considered when rangelands are grazed in
a sustainable fashion rangeland plants
are able to grow grow and reproduce
soils are protected and the resource is
conserved for the future improper
grazing can lead to weat infestations
and soil erosion leading to A reduced
Forge base degraded rangelands can be
rehabilitated but recovery may take
years and inputs such as seaing or other
treatments can be
expensive because rangelands are so
critical for Wyoming's livestock and
Wildlife it's important that we use them
in sustainable ways from the University
of Wyoming extension I'm Barton Stan
exploring the nature of
[Music]
Wyoming